(guitar strumming)
- What?
♫ Hey ♫
(elves screaming)
- Santa, what are you doing?
- Chris, I've been gay for
a while, you know this.
It wasn't just last year.
- Alright well, I'll go
give this to someone else.
- Yeah, I'd suggest that.
- [Chris] I hate Christmas!
- Ho ho ho!
(shouting indistinctly)
- Like a mother (beep) goat honey,
you look crazy!
Can you even fly with those thighs?
Look at that nose, can't even
light up a god (beep) fridge!
I'm Olive, bitch!
- Oooh, sleigh.
(sleigh bells ringing)
Sleigh, think about it.
(laughing)
(wretching)
- [Girl] Whoa!
(objects clattering)
(groaning)
♫ My wish come true
♫ Baby
♫ All I want for Christmas is
♫ Food baby
- Merry Christmas!
- Happy Hanukkah!
- Happy New Year!
- And chicken and rice!
♫ Chicken and rice, chicken and rice
♫ Chicken and rice, chicken and rice ♫
(singing indistinctly)